[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi
and welcome to Episode
Number 17 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm very sleepy.
MARK MANDEL: You're very--
It's a bit early in the morning
still?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
very early today.
Yup.
So and how about you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
just a little sleepy.
Yeah, a little bit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we
woke up very early today
to be able to interview
two TDs from South Africa.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It was a really
interesting conversation
with Hiren and Dale talking
about some really interesting
challenges they have around
the connectivity they have
in internet there and
some of the challenges
they have around that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it's
very interesting connectivity,
because they are far away
from big data centers,
but also because the mobile
networks in the country
are actually not as reliable
as one could expect.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So things drop out
a lot apparently.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
we're going to be talking
about connectivity and how to
be a good developer in Africa
with them today.
And then by the
end of the episode,
we're going to be discussing
something quite similar.
Someone asked this
question, which is-- OK,
so I want to develop a mobile
application that is reliable
even though the
connectivity is not.
How do I do that?
MARK MANDEL: That's
a very good question.
Can't wait to hear the answer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, yeah, we'll be
talking about that at the end.
But before that-- cool
thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
So cool thing of
the week this week
is pretty much a
little self-serving.
Next week, we're both
going to at GCP Next.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And
I'm pretty excited,
because we're going to be
bringing down our microphones.
We're going to bring
down our headsets.
And we're going to be at
the event doing recordings
with people and interviews.
So if you're at GCP Next, we'd
definitely love to talk to you.
Please come over-- at the
very least, come and say hi.
But if we can have a
five-minute, ten-minute chat
with you, talk to
you about the event,
and how you're using
Google Cloud Platform,
and how you're just
enjoying life in general,
we'd totally love to do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that'd be awesome.
I'm really looking
forward to seeing
how many of the
people at GCP Next
actually have heard
ever this podcast.
And so if you're one of
them, just come say hi.
You will make our day.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
would be awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That
But if you can't make GCP next--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
if you can not make it,
because San Francisco is
maybe far away from you--
it's maybe a pretty
long flight, don't
worry, because we actually have
GCP Next Extended local viewing
parties.
So we're going to have a
link on the show notes,
but basically you can
go and see GCP Next live
from any of many, many places.
And, surprisingly-- I
was looking on the map,
and the continent with the
largest number of local viewing
parties is Africa.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no,
actually they're winning,
I think basically is
what it boils down to.
They are winning, and I
think some other countries
need to catch up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, Nigeria
has seven local viewing
parties, which is
more than Europe.
MARK MANDEL: That's crazy.
That's amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's amazing.
So yeah, very, very
happy that people
are very interested on
Google Cloud Platform.
And, actually, we're going to
be talking about Africa today
during the main
content of the podcast,
so I think that it is amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no,
I think it's great.
I'm not-- my
hometown, Australia,
I think you need
to lift your game.
I'm not seeing any
local viewing parties.
So let's get at it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK,
same for Barcelona.
Barcelona, what's going on?
MARK MANDEL: So if you want to
start your own local viewing
party, very simple.
You can actually go
to the same website.
And you can-- there's a button
there called, "host your own,"
and you can actually
enter in your details
for a Next Extended
event request.
So get on that.
Still got some time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, get on that.
And not only you will get
access to the live stream, which
is by the way, open to
everyone, but also you
will get support from
our marketing team
to help you organize
this thing and host it
and so everybody will
have a good time.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So I think that it's time
to travel over the network
and go talk to our friends
down in South Africa.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Let's do it.
Today we're joined by two
guests that are very far
away from where we are today.
We had joined by Hiren Patel
and Dale Humby, two Google
Developer experts
from South Africa.
How are you gentlemen
doing this morning?
HIREN PATEL: Very good.
Thank you.
DALE HUMBY: Hi, Mark.
Hi Francesc.
Good, thanks.
MARK MANDEL: So it's-- well,
it's early in the morning San
Francisco time here at 8 a.m.
What time is it where you are?
DALE HUMBY: It's a little
after 6:00 p.m. here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Here I'm
still having my first coffee.
MARK MANDEL: It's very
early in the morning,
especially for San Francisco.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Especially for me
MARK MANDEL: Especially
for you, yeah.
So thank you both of you very
much for joining us today.
I'm quite excited
to talk to both you,
and I think there are some
really interesting things
that we can talk about.
But why don't we get
some background first.
Hiren, why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself?
HIREN PATEL: Sure.
So my name is Hiren
Patel, and I'm
a contract developer based
in Cape Town, South Africa,
as you've said.
I'm a Google Developer expert
for Google Cloud Platform.
So I come from 10 years of
Linux system administration
with Linux and Unix.
And I've since transitioned
into more of a DevOps role,
following web apps these days,
both backend and front end,
and doing some mobile
work with Android.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
What about you, Dale?
DALE HUMBY: My
name is Dale Humby,
and I'm also a Google
Developer expert
on the Cloud Platform, based out
of Cape Town in South Africa.
And I'm the CTO of a local
startup called Nomanini.
And I run the tech team
of industrial designers,
electrical engineers,
some firmware
and backend and
front end developers
as well, building
point-of-sale systems
for selling airtime and
electricity around Africa.
MARK MANDEL: Very interesting.
Very, very interesting.
Jeez, where do we want to start?
There so many interesting
things to talk about.
All right, Dale, you
were just speaking.
Why don't you tell
us a little bit more
about the point-of-sale
systems, what
sort of projects you're working
on, the things that you do?
DALE HUMBY: Sure.
Well, we've developed a
mobile point-of-sale system
to enable people to
buy essential services,
like mobile airtime and
prepaid electricity cheaply
in developing countries,
specifically around Africa.
We've built our own
point-of-sale system
from the ground up
to be really robust
and provide access
to essential services
for guys who can't necessarily
get them easily or cheaply.
We built our whole backend
on the Google Cloud Platform
and using some cool
technologies like AngularJS
for our front end and
running on Google App
Engine for our backend,
exploring Container Engine.
And we use Datastore and
BigQuery really heavily.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
What about you, Hiren?
HIREN PATEL: Cool.
So I transitioned
into a DevOps role
doing some Google App Engine
work for startups in Cape Town.
This was my first use of
Google Cloud Platform.
But my current project
actually involves
building a platform
for businesses
to collect feedback on
products and service
from their customers.
It will then allow them
to visualize this feedback
in various ways
using a dashboard
and allows them to spot trends
and improvements and things
like that.
So the current
server-side stack for me
includes Python and Django
with some customized forms.
This is deployed with
Docker and Kubernetes
on Google Container Engine.
I'm using persistent
storage via the Datastore.
And I'm using Google Charts for
the dashboard at the moment,
making use of the Python library
that's available for charts,
which was quite convenient.
I'm also looking to use
material charts at a later point
when that moves out of beta.
The client-side stack
for the data collection
consists of Django web
forms with Material Design
Lite to put some material
design on the web for me,
focusing on mobile use
case here and fluid design.
So I chose the stack
I chose, because I
am most familiar with Python.
My background involves
using Python throughout.
And I quite like the concept of
deploying Docker and container
management solutions such as
Kubernetes over virtual machine
deployment-style deployments.
And Container Engine was my
choice, because, at the moment,
it seems to be the best
place for hosted Kubernetes
as far as I've seen out there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So all of this sounds
very interesting,
but at the same
time quite standard.
It's something that I could
expect many other people
in San Francisco doing
something similar.
But I am sure that doing
this in South Africa
involves some different things.
Like, how is the infrastructure?
Is it different?
Is it hard to develop?
I know that in here
when I am in a hotel,
and I try to do [INAUDIBLE]
of something big,
it's going to take a long time.
What about down there?
DALE HUMBY: Sure.
So a particularly
interesting thing for me
is within South Africa the
connectivity scenario has
gotten a bit better
over the years.
I couldn't say the same for
the rest of Africa, sadly.
Although for me a particular
challenge is mobile data
costs still remain quite
high within South Africa.
And the impact of that is felt
not just by consumers, but also
by small- to
medium-sized businesses.
A recent example of
having run into that-- I
was doing some work
for a company that
had about 150 sales
reps out in the field.
And these sales reps had
tablet devices with SIM cards
for connectivity, and
they were doing data
capturing using these devices.
And on one fine day, a
frenzy of support cases
came in whereby all these
devices stopped working.
And it turned out to be that
the company had contracted
a package for all these SIM
cards from a mobile network
operator, and they ended
up getting their data cap
for this package.
And so, basically, all the
sales reps jobs came to an end
for the rest of that day.
So that was quite
interesting to see.
I mean they had to go
and investigate the data
usage afterwards and come up
with plans to try and keep
costs down, to reduce the
amount of data being used.
So data cost is
still something being
felt by businesses
and consumers,
and it's quite a challenge in
South Africa at the moment.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I really
like that you categorize it
as something
"interesting" to see.
I'm pretty sure
that the people that
were on field with tablet
that were completely bricked,
they were not that happy.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure the
word they weren't using
was interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really cool.
What about you, Dale, do
you have any story to share?
DALE HUMBY: Yeah.
Most of our business
is up in Africa,
and definitely South Africa is
the most advanced when it comes
to services being available.
A lot of places where
we operate the services
are incredibly unreliable.
Electricity can be down for
18 hours a day sometimes.
So in the evenings you might
have maybe just a few hours
to charge your phone
or your tablet.
And that's got to last
you one or two days.
So we can't just leave our
phones on charge all the time
and expect them to
carry on working,
because the power is out a lot.
Also the mobile networks
are very overloaded,
and there's limited connection
to the outside world
very often.
So you find that in the
evenings the mobile networks
will prioritize voice
traffic over data traffic.
So a lot of your websites just
stop working or your web apps
just stop getting a
data connection through,
which is really frustrating
if you're trying to use
Google Maps or something.
And sometimes a whole
fiber cable will go down.
And I think over the
last year sometime--
I can't remember exactly
which month it was--
the entire country of Nigeria
was offline for a day,
because the fiber went down.
And when a country is
isolated like that,
no news can get
in or out easily,
and it's very frustrating.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
And do you find as well
that device penetration is
quite different there?
I mean, obviously-- I know
living here, technically, well,
living here in the
bubble in San Francisco,
I've got the latest
Android device.
I've got a nice fast laptop.
Do you find that you get a
different device penetration
as well?
DALE HUMBY: Yeah.
A lot of people still
have feature phones.
And you know the first time
they get an Android device,
it's quite a challenge
to try and teach people
what a touchscreen is.
They've never used a
touchscreen before.
And even with the latest trends
in [? icontariel ?] design,
where the icons are
very flat, the buttons
don't necessarily look
like buttons anymore.
And trying to teach guys
what the different actions do
is quite a challenge
when they haven't
been through the last 10 years
of user interface development.
And also the feature
phones that now
are going displaced by
cheaper Android phones
are still-- those Android
phones are the very low end
ones so in some cases
still running like KitKat
from a few years ago.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So how
do you deal with this?
Is there any kind of specific
technology or some kind
of practices that you apply to
make sure that, one, the data
restrictions are not
a big problem as I
think they could be?
And, two, that , people that
don't have the background using
smartphones for years are
able to still use your apps?
DALE HUMBY: Hiren, do you
want to answer this one?
HIREN PATEL: Yeah.
I think it's quite
a tricky situation.
I'm not sure about the
market in the rest of Africa,
but in South Africa,
specifically, I
know there's been a whole
bunch of cheap smartphones
that have recently
hit the market.
Particularly, I
think, I'm not sure
if it's a South
African culture thing,
but people sort of tend to
get used to using the devices
and pick it up quickly enough.
I haven't really worked in
the space of providing apps
in terms of providing them on
the place for our consumers
as such.
I've done more
business-sided apps.
And the users of my
apps are I wouldn't
say people who are using
it for the first time.
So I haven't really battled
in that space all that much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
What about what about you, Dale?
You mentioned that one of the
things that you do-- if I'm not
mistaking it now-- is you
provide an application
so people can buy electricity?
DALE HUMBY: Actually,
we provide a whole piece
of our own hardware.
A point-of-sale terminal that
we developed from the ground up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, interesting.
DALE HUMBY: And because a lot
of people only potentially
semi-literate, and they're
not used to smartphones,
we purposefully avoided
that paradigm for now
and gone for devices
that have either just
buttons and no screen or a
very simple screen with very
obvious menus and buttons to
try and educate them in this.
And we found that that's
working really well.
And with some of our
more advanced clients,
moving them over to
Android terminals.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
So since it is the Google
Cloud Platform Podcast,
do these-- well, I don't know
if they're unique challenges,
but do these
particular challenges,
do they dictate what sort of
backend solutions that you use?
You've talked about App Engine.
You've both talked
about Kubernetes.
Is it something that is
affected by that sort of stuff?
Or is it not necessarily?
HIREN PATEL: Yes.
So for me coming from
Google App Engine,
I think I choose Google
Cloud Platform products
more for the tools and
the developer convenience
it gives me.
If the product or the platform
come with technologies
that help our specific
issues, then that's
kind of a bonus for me.
But I choose them more for
the convenience and the tools
and the experience
of development.
MARK MANDEL: That's fair enough.
DALE HUMBY: And I tend
to echo what Hiren said.
When we set out we had a
big challenge ahead of us
to build our hardware.
And we wanted a backend that
we could just rely on and not
have to spend months
setting up, so that's
why we chose App Engine,
because it was just
the platform that we could write
our Python code and deploy.
And that's stood us in
incredibly good stead
for the last four or five
years that we've been on it.
And, yeah, I think--
what other reasons have
I got for App Engine or Cloud?
I think the tooling that's been
developed around especially
with monitoring and logging
has been a huge help
as we've grown-- got bigger
to allow us to find problems
with our stack with our
application code specifically.
We've got dashboards
throughout the office with all
the monitoring on and so we
can see in real time what's
happening on our system.
And it's just a
great benefit to us
that we don't have to worry
about keeping the servers up
and running when we've got
thousands of points of sales
to keep running, which
is challenge enough.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
All right.
Very cool.
So what sort of
upcoming technologies
that you gentlemen
particularly are excited
by, either in general
or maybe him in relation
to the challenges you're
facing there in Africa?
HIREN PATEL: Cool.
So, yeah, with Africa
being mostly mobile,
and the mobile being mostly
web, there are two upcoming
technologies in the web space
which I'm quite excited about,
which I think will affect
a number of us here.
The first one is Service
Worker for the web, which
is an exciting new
browser standard that's
coming together to offer rich
offline and powerful caching.
And I think what
that's going to give
us is web app experience
that's not only fast,
but that's going to use
less data, two things which
are key problems for us here.
I'm looking to use this
in the current project,
as well, for uses such as
offline kiosks or kiosks where
the internet connection
may be flaky.
And the second piece
of web technology
that I'm really
looking forward to
is the HTTP save data
client hint header.
This lets the
browser or the client
explicitly tell the server
that it wants to save data,
and the server can serve down
different resources altogether
based on this.
I think the server
sending down resources
based on connection speeds
or device types, which
we have today is
great, but I feel
like there's a real
need for us here
to be able to explicitly use
data saving features even
on fast connections, because
of the prices of our data.
So I read somewhere
recently that 50%
of smartphone users in India
switch their data connection
off.
They don't keep it
on all the time.
And my first thought was,
well, I do the same thing here.
MARK MANDEL: Fair enough.
So you want some useful
ways to be able to say,
OK, I'm going to
turn on my data,
grab something, use
it, then turn it off,
and hopefully I can
still use it in sort
of like an offline mode.
HIREN PATEL: Exactly.
As well as when I am
using it, the server
should be smart about what it
serves me if I'm out and about,
and I just want to
pull up some resource
to get some information
that I don't want the server
to serve me things that's
going to cost me money
that it doesn't need to.
MARK MANDEL: That's
totally fair enough.
Dale, anything to add?
DALE HUMBY: The proliferation of
cheap Android phones is great.
It's really bringing the
cost of hardware down
and this is got a
massive positive effect
on consumer
electronics in general,
not just phones-- like RAM
and Flash, the cellphone GSM
modules, GPS
modules, all of that
is so much cheaper than
it was five years ago.
And that's not just
due to Moore's law,
it's because the Android
phones and their proliferation
have meant that these
processes are on the market
and we can use them in any
source of electronics, which
has got a huge benefit
for people developing
tools in Africa who want to
build their own electronics
and build their own solutions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
I was right now
checking for something
that I was curious about,
which is sometimes consumers,
especially users of
Google Cloud Platform,
or actually Asia or
Amazon, they consider
being close to a data center
to be something really, really
interesting.
I was looking at the maps.
You could not be farther
away from a data center,
literally, from any data center.
Does that have an impact
on the way you develop too?
It's not only the fact that from
your customers to your servers
there may be a delay, but even
from you to a data center,
there's also delay.
Is that something that you feel?
DALE HUMBY: Yeah, we'd
wish Google would build us
a data center in Africa.
That would be so much better.
But in all seriousness,
the connectivity,
or the lag over the GSM network,
specifically GPRS or EDGE
is pretty bad anyway, so
the 180 millisecond ping
time to our data
center in the US
is not so bad when you
consider that sometimes
over the mobile network you've
got a three second ping time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Wow.
DALE HUMBY: You have
to rely on caching.
And caching for
the speed, but also
caching if the network
goes down and you still
want the content locally.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
trying to find a map.
I can't seem to find it.
Obviously, we have our
points of presence,
so I'm wondering whether we
have one in South Africa.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
that may be interesting.
DALE HUMBY: Yeah,
Johannesburg's got a pop.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's very interesting.
And that's interesting that the
same way you optimize a program
by finding the slowest
part and not trying
to optimize just randomly.
Here you've-- a ping on the GSM
network might take up to three
seconds.
Yeah, I don't think the problem
is the connectivity to the data
center.
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's crazy.
DALE HUMBY: Look, it's
not always like that.
But it can go like
that sometimes.
And just everything
goes out when
you've got such bad ping times.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that is very interesting.
I know that in here
I really appreciate
when I can use an application
offline, because it's something
that can be useful sometimes.
But it's more like a little plus
that I appreciate rather than,
oh, yeah, if not, I
cannot really use it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It gives me a little
perspective on-- I
used to live in
Australia, where I always
complained about how slow
the bandwidth there is.
And now I'm like, OK, so
maybe that's not as bad
as like it was in my mind.
DALE HUMBY: I think with
the local point of presence
and the EDGE caches, there
are multiple ones that Google
supplies around Africa,
so that does help,
if you sort out your
caching headers correctly
then some of the static
content is at least faster.
And everything you just
do through Ajax callbacks.
HIREN PATEL: Yeah.
I tend to agree.
I think it depends very
specifically on the application
itself.
And if it can tolerate
a bit of latency,
then the caching is
generally good enough
to give the user an
experience that's OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
something related to this
that we actually
talked a little bit
while preparing this interview,
which is YouTube Red.
I don't know if you have tried
since YouTube Red allowing
you to download videos from
YouTube directly for free
so you can watch them later on.
MARK MANDEL: Now, it's for
free only in South Africa.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For free only
in South Africa, by the way.
I think it may be in other
countries of Africa too.
MARK MANDEL: OK, fair enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
it's definitely not
free in the United States.
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
have you tried it?
HIREN PATEL: I haven't as yet.
I previously used another
tool, but this is great,
if if this would allow me
to do it more conveniently,
I definitely would look into it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do you
think that it's something
that your users
could appreciate?
Like the fact that
it's not only that they
can use your
application offline,
but they actually can prepare
for long offline periods
by preparing, downloading
documents, and so on.
DALE HUMBY: Yeah, absolutely.
And if you're at the
office or an internet cafe,
then you can use
the Wi-Fi connection
to download all your content.
And then when you're
roaming around or at home,
then you don't have to use your
mobile connection at all, which
saves quite a lot of money.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that is very interesting.
I would like to know if there's
some other listeners that
might be using these
kind of technologies,
these kind of techniques to make
their applications more usable
really in some other parts
of the world, really.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
definitely a great perspective
in that when you're-- I
think often we tend to think
of things as totally
always connected,
just because of where
we are and what we do.
But thinking about it
from the perspective,
OK, what happens when
you're disconnected
on a regular basis, not
just on an airplane.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
Not even in airplanes
we're disconnected anymore,
most of the time.
MARK MANDEL: Well, yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
So we're sort of running
out of time a little bit,
but is there anything
that either of you
want to mention
either to plug or you
want to talk about
before we wrap things up?
Dale?
DALE HUMBY: Oh yeah.
Going back to some things
I'm looking forward to.
NFC and cashless
payments is something
I'm really excited
to see developing
across the continent.
Carrying cash can be dangerous
and without the technology
to replace cash,
there's no other option.
It needs to be fast and easy.
And with NFC and
contactless payments,
it allows you to not have
to carry cash around.
So as people get more phones,
and they move their cash
into bank accounts, and hardware
manufacturers start supporting
NFC and contactless
payments, I think,
it's going to be a
really exciting space.
HIREN PATEL: Yeah, and
in terms of my side,
I think what I'd like to
see is for all of Africa
coming online.
I think that would be great.
If you look at the moment at
the Wikipedia page on percentage
of population of
people online for all
the different
countries, you'll see
that Africa's lagging
a whole lot compared
to the rest of the world.
I think it'd be great to see
programs such as Android One
and so on bringing cheap
devices into the space
and bringing everyone online.
MARK MANDEL: Well, thank
you very much to both
of you for joining us today.
I know it's a little
late in your afternoon.
It's been a really
interesting conversation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And I'm really
looking forward to see
what you're able to build
with the new technologies you
say you're waiting for.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
most definitely.
DALE HUMBY: Thank you
very much for having us.
HIREN PATEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
Goodbye.
MARK MANDEL: Cheers.
Thank you so much to Hiren
and Dale for joining us.
That was a really
interesting conversation
and definitely opened my
eyes up to maybe a little bit
of my privilege of using the
internet and being as connected
as I am.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, clearly.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, which
is good, which is good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't think I
will complain that much anymore
about my mobile connectivity
in San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
So we have a good lead
now into our question
of the week from our
previous conversation, which
is sort of about connectivity.
We sort of got
asked the question,
so when I'm developing
mobile applications,
and maybe I have spotty
connectivity, right,
maybe it drops out
on a regular basis.
Maybe it's for
people who fly a lot
or go into places where
they don't necessarily have
connection to the internet.
How can Google Cloud
Platform help you
when you're offline
a lot of the time?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
how can the Cloud
help you when you have
access to the Cloud?
So surprisingly, the
answer is we have
actually something really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Which I really did not expect.
But I was looking
for it while we
were talking with
Hiren and Dale,
and I saw that we
have Firebase offline.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, OK.
So Firebase has inbuilt support
for offline capabilities?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And there's some of the stuff
that you can do for the web,
but it's especially powerful
for Android and iOS.
And basically what it does
is it keeps a local copy
of a Firebase database.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And it allows you
to basically do all
the modifications,
reads, and writes on it.
And then once you
get connected again,
it syncs to the remote database.
MARK MANDEL: So you
don't have to worry
about any of that complicated
stuff of syncing data
back again and managing
conflicts and doing
that sort of stuff.
It manages that for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and not only that,
but it also helps you
manage things like presence.
So if you imagine
that you have a chat,
you could have
something where you can
see who is online, who is not.
You could see if
you online or not.
And even if you're not, you
can still send messages,
and those messages will
actually be sent to the chat
once you get online.
Even more crazy than that,
you can even do transactions.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
That's crazy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's pretty crazy.
So you can do transactions
on the database,
and the transactions will be
tried once you get online.
And they could fail, of course,
but if you have something
like I just need to
increase this I counter,
probably if that counter
changed since you were offline,
it will fail, and you will get
a notification saying, hey,
that actually failed,
you have to retry.
But if you have something
different, which
is like maybe the user decided
to change their username,
or something of that,
that's something
that only them can do, so that
was something that probably
will succeed
whenever you actually
are connected to the network.
So that's actually
something really cool.
It really makes me
think about what
you can do with
Google Docs, where
you can download something
and start working on it.
And once you're-- so
it's basically like that
deteriorated mode, where you
don't have access to the full
functionality, but still you
can get working and do a lot
of stuff with your
application, which is great.
I really like it.
MARK MANDEL: Really nice.
I really like that too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so we're going
to have the link to the
show, and there's actually
a pretty old blog post.
It's actually from
May 2015, announcing
offline mobile
support, but I actually
don't know how many people are
aware of this, so I thought
it was interesting to mention.
MARK MANDEL: No, no,
no, I really like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So before we
finish with the episode today,
what are you going to be up to?
MARK MANDEL: So as of
literally right now,
I will be physically in GDC, so
I'll be at the Game Developers
Conference in San Francisco.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
I will be there too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
you'll be there a little
bit as well, running
some Cloud spin.
Next week we will
both be at GCP Next--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, we will.
MARK MANDEL: --as we
talked about earlier.
But I also just
got a notification
that I will be speaking at Open
Source North in Bloomington.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: In June the 9th.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Bloomington?
MARK MANDEL: MN--
I'm Australian--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
going to MN is Montana.
But I don't even know.
I'm not American either, I'm
not saying that Montana--
MARK MANDEL: Minnesota.
Minnesota.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Montana might be MO.
I don't know.
We should learn some states.
Whatever.
MARK MANDEL: How about yourself?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
congratulations on that.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
also got accepted
for a very cool conference.
I'm actually very
excited about this.
It's one of my favorite
conferences in the world.
I'm going to be
speaking at GopherCon.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I
bet you are excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
very, very excited.
So it's in Denver in July.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I still
have time to prepare my talk.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So maybe we should
repeat our way
of contacting us very quick.
So I'm going to say the name.
You say the thing.
Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: /r/GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Google+
MARK MANDEL: +GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: E-mail.
MARK MANDEL: Hello@GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And our web page.
MARK MANDEL: GCPpodcast.com
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And that's
pretty much it, right?
MARK MANDEL: Slack.
#podcast on the GCP
Podcast Slack community.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
I actually totally forgot
about that, but, yeah,
it's probably the easiest way--
the fastest way to contact us.
Great.
So thank you so much again
for being with me today, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you for being with me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]